>>> HELLO, EVERYONE.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME, AND
HAPPY MOTHER'S DAY.
WE BEGIN WITH THIS BREAKING
NEWS.
FIRST LADY JILL BIDEN TODAY
MAKING A SURPRISE VISIT TO
UKRAINE ON THIS MOTHER'S DAY.
SHE HAS CROSSED THE BORDER FROM
SLO VOK YA WHERE SHE WAS ON AN
OFFICIAL VISIT.
PART OF HER FOUR-DAY TRIP TO
EASTERN EUROPE.
THERE WAS THIS EMOTIONAL MOMENT
TODAY WHEN SHE MET WITH
UKRAINE'S FIRST LADY WHO HAS NOT
MADE A PUBLIC APPEARANCE SINCE
THE START OF THE WAR IN
FEBRUARY.
SEE RIGHT THERE, EXCHANGE OF
FLOWERS.
AR LET SIGNS IS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
KATE BENNETT JOINS US FROM
TRAVELING WITH THE FIRST LADY.
KATE, WHAT DO WE NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT THIS VISIT?
>> Reporter: WELL, WE'RE BACK IN
SLOVAKIA TONIGHT.
EARLIER TODAY WE MADE THE
SURPRISE TRIP WITH THE FIRST
LADY INTO THE SOUTH WESTERN
CORNER OF UKRAINE.
A 15-MINUTE DRIVE FROM THE
BORDER.
BESIDES THE TRIP ON MOTHER'S
DAY, THE BIGGEST SURPRISE WAS
THE FIRST LADY OF UKRAINE.
THEY'VE EXCHANGED
CORRESPONDENCE, AND MEETING
TODAY WAS A BIG DEAL.
NOT ONLY IS A FIRST LADY GOING
INTO AN ACTIVE WAR ZONE.
THIS IS ALSO THE WIFE OF THE
PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE WHO HAS
TRIED TO KEEP UNDER COVER.
THE PUBLIC HAS NOT SEEN HER.
THE TWO WOMEN TOGETHER ON
MOTHER'S DAY.
AS DR. BIDEN SAID, IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FROM AMERICA ON MOTHER'S DAY FOR
UKRAINE.
NOW, THE TWO WOMEN HELD A
BILATERAL BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
FOR ABOUT A HALF HOUR OR SO THAT
THE PRESS DIDN'T GET TO SEE.
I'M TOLD THEY TALKED ABOUT
ESPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH.
THE FIRST LADY OF UKRAINE IS
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CITIZENS OF HER COUNTRY, THE
SOLDIERS INVOLVED IN THE BLOODY
INVASION BY RUSSIA OF THE
HOMELAND.
SHE WONDERS WHO WILL HAPPEN TO
THEM AFTER THE WAR DOES END.
OF COURSE, DR. BIDEN, A BIG
PROPONENT OF MENTAL HEALTH, OF
CHILDREN, EDUCATION.
THIS WAS SOMETHING THE TWO WOMEN
CONVERSED ABOUT FOR SOME TIME.
IT WAS EMOTIONAL.
THERE WERE KIDS.
THIS IS A FORMER SCHOOL THAT HAS
BEEN TURNED INTO TEMPORARY
HOUSING FOR FAMILIES THAT HAVE
BEEN DISPLACED BY THE WAR.
SO IMAGINE YOUR LOCAL HIGH
SCHOOL ALL THE SUDDEN BECOMES
SORT OF A SMALL APARTMENT FOR
PEOPLE WHO NO LONGER HAVE HOMES.
THE TWO FIRST LADIES DID AN ARTS
AND CRAFTS PROJECT.
THEY WERE CLOSE.
YOU COULD TELL THERE WAS A
CONNECTION.
DR. BIDEN'S ENTIRE TRIP HAS BEEN
ABOUT WOMEN, MOTHERS AND
CHILDREN.
THIS IS THE CULMINATION.
TONIGHT SHE WRAPS IT UP AND
HEADS BACK TO WASHINGTON.
>> A SURPRISE VISIT TO THE REST
OF THE WORLD, BUT CLEARLY A
WELCOME VISIT THERE TO THE FIRST
LADY OF UKRAINE.
ARLETTE, AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
THE MEETING.
>> Reporter: THE PURPOSE OF THE
MEETING WAS TWO-FOLD.
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND G7 LEADERS
EXPRESSING SOLIDARITY WITH
UKRAINE BUT ALSO THE COMMITMENT
TO FURTHER PUNISHING RUSSIA
THROUGH SANCTIONS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PHOTO OF THE
MEETING, THE PRESIDENT HELD THE
CALL FROM HIS HOME IN DELAWARE.
IT LASTED A LITTLE OVER AN HOUR.
IF YOU LOOK CLOSELY, THE
CANADIAN PRIME MINISTER WAS IN
THE ROOM IN UKRAINE WITH
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY AS
THE LEADERS ALL HELD THIS PHONE
CALL.
THE U.S. AND ALLIES SAID THEY
WOULD FURTHER PROVIDE MILITARY
AND ECONOMIC ASSISTANCE TO
UKRAINE.
IN A STATEMENT RELEASED AFTER
THE CALL, THEY SAID THERE WOULD
BE MORE FINANCIAL AID GOING TO
THE COUNTRY IN THE COMING WEEKS.
BUT THEY ALSO TALKED ABOUT THE
NEED TO RAMP UP THE SANCTIONS
AGAINST RUSSIA.
THE U.S. TODAY ROLLING OUT A NEW
PACKAGE OF SANCTIONS THAT IN
PART TARGET THREE RUSSIAN
STATE-RUN TV STATIONS.
IT BANS U.S. ADVERTISING ON
THOSE STATIONS.
ADDITIONALLY, IT'S PROHIBITING
THE U.S. PROVIDED MANAGEMENT AND
CONSULTING SERVICES TO COMPANIES
AS WELL AS IMPOSING EXPORT
CONTROLS ON THE INDUSTRIAL
SECTOR AND RAMPING UP VISA
RESTRICTIONS ON MORE THAN 2500
RUSSIANS AND BELARUSIONS.
IN THE G7 STATEMENT RELEASED
AFTER THE CALL, U.S. AND ALLIED
COUNTRIES COMMITTED TO PHASING
OUT RUSSIAN GAS AND ENERGY.
OF COURSE, THE U.S. HAS ALREADY
BANNED RUSSIAN ENERGY IMPORTS.
THAT IS NOTEWORTHY AS THE
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES ARE MUCH MORE
RELIANT ON RUSSIAN OIL AND
ENERGY COMPARED TO THE UNITED
STATES.
ADDITIONALLY TODAY, THE ACTING
U.S. AMBASSADOR TO UKRAINE AND
OTHER OFFICIALS TRAVELED TO KYIV
AFTER THEY HAD LEFT THE EMBASSY
THERE BACK IN MID FEBRUARY.
JUST ANOTHER SIGN OF SUPPORT
WITH UKRAINE, ESPECIALLY AS
RUSSIA IS EXPECTED TO CELEBRATE
VICTORY DAY TOMORROW.
THE U.S. AND THE ALLIES TRYING
TO REINFORCE TO UKRAINE AND SHOW
THEIR UNWAVERING SUPPORT FOR THE
COUNTRY AMID THIS WAR.
>> ALL RIGHT.
ARLETTE SIGNS AND KATE BENNETT,
THANK YOU TO YOU BOTH.
>>> THE FIRST LADY'S VISIT
HAPPENING AMID HORRIFIC NEW
VIOLENCE BROUGHT ON BY RUSSIA'S
ON SLIGHT.
AT LEAST 60 PEOPLE ARE FEARED
DEAD AFTER A RUSSIAN AIR STRIKE
HIT A SCHOOL IN THE LUHANSK
REGION.
THE SCHOOL HAD BEEN ACTING AS A
SHELTER FOR NEARLY 100 PEOPLE.
THE ATTACK COMES ON UKRAINE'S
DAY OF REMEMBRANCE AND
RECONCILIATION HELD IN HONOR OF
THOSE WHO LOST THEIR LIVES
DURING WORLD WAR II.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY OFFERING THE
SOBERING REMARKS ON THIS SACRED
DAY.
>> Translator: THIS YEAR WE SAY
NEVER AGAIN DIFFERENTLY.
WE HEAR NEVER AGAIN DIFFERENTLY.
IT SOUNDS PAINFUL, CRUEL,
WITHOUT AN EXCLAMATION, BUT WITH
A QUESTION MARK YOU SAY NEVER
AGAIN, TELL UKRAINE ABOUT IT.
>> CNN'S SCOTT McLEAN IS IN LVIV
COVERING THE LATEST ROUND OF
EVENTS THERE.
SO SCOTT, WHAT MORE ARE YOU
LEARNING ABOUT THE ATTACK AT
THAT SCHOOL?
>> FREDRICKA, THE 90 PEOPLE
ACCORDING TO A LOCAL MILITARY
OFFICIAL WERE SHELTERING INSIDE
THE SCHOOL BECAUSE MOST OF THE
REST OF THE VILLAGE WAS BOMBED
OUT.
IT WAS ONE OF THE LAST REMAINING
GOOD PLACES TO ACTUALLY SHELTER
THERE, AND OUR COLLEAGUES
ACTUALLY MANAGED TO GET TO THAT
AREA TO SPEAK WITH SOME OF THE
SURVIVORS FROM THIS VILLAGE, AND
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IS
ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE.
ONE MAN SAID THAT IT WAS JUST
ALL AT ONCE, LIKE FLIPPING A
LIGHT SWITCH.
THE LIGHTS WENT OUT.
ALL THREE OF THE FLOORS
COLLAPSED ON TOP OF THEM AND
THEY COULD NOT UNDERSTAND WHAT
WAS GOING ON.
ANOTHER MAN SAID HE WAS ONE OF
THE FIRST ONES OUT OF THAT
BUILDING.
HE WAS SORT OF CHUCKING WRIKS --
BRICKS TO THE SIDE TO TRY TO GET
OUT WITH THE HELP OF VILLAGERS
TRYING TO HELP WITH PEOPLE
GETTING OUT FROM UNDER THERE.
HE SAID AMONG THE PEOPLE
SHELTERING THERE, ELDERLY PEOPLE
AND CHILDREN.
AND ONE OF THE MEN WHOSE HEAD
WAS VISIBLY BANDAGED, VISIBLY
INJURED SAID THAT A SLAB OF
CONCRETE HAD COME DOWN ON HIM IN
ADDITION TO SOME OTHER ROCKS AND
WHEN HE GOT OUT OF THAT FROM
UNDER THAT SCHOOL, HE SAID HE
FELT LIKE A DRUNK MAN JUST
COMPLETELY, COMPLETELY LOST.
SO AT LAST WORD, THERE WERE 27
PEOPLE WHO MANAGED TO SURVIVE.
BUT IT'S VERY LIKELY, ACCORDING
TO LOCAL OFFICIALS, THAT 60
PEOPLE DID NOT GET OUT BECAUSE
EVEN THOUGH SEARCH AND RESCUE IS
ONGOING, JUST GIVEN THE STATE OF
THINGS, THEY SAY IT'S EXTREMELY
UNLIKELY THERE'S STILL ANYONE
ALIVE UNDER THAT RUBBLE.
JUST A LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT
HERE.
THIS VILLAGE IS ABOUT SEVEN
MILES OR SO WEST OF THE
FRONTLINES.
IT'S TAKEN SOME HEAVY SHELLING
IN RECENT WEEKS AS THE RUSSIANS
TRIED TO PUSH THROUGH THAT
FRONTLINE, BREAK THROUGH THE
UKRAINIAN FRONTLINES.
THERE WAS AN EVACUATION ABOUT
TWO WEEKS AGO THAT SUCCESSFULLY
MANAGED TO GET ROUGHLY 50 PEOPLE
OUT INCLUDING SOME CHILDREN, BUT
CLEARLY NOT EVERYONE TOOK THE
OPPORTUNITY OR COULD TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET OUT THEN.
>> SO SAD.
ALL RIGHT.
SCOTT McLEAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LET'S TALK MORE ABOUT THIS.
LET'S BRING IN KIM DOZIER, A CNN
GLOBAL AFFAIRS ANALYST AND
CORRESPONDENT FOR "TIME".
THEY CONTINUE TO ACCUSE RUSSIA
OF NOT KEEPING ITS WORD ON
INVASIONS.
IT'S NOT JUST AN ACCUSATION,
THERE'S EVIDENCE.
DOES ANYONE BELIEVE RUSSIA IS
GOING TO RESPECT ANY OTHER CALLS
FOR EVACUATION WHEN CONTINUED
EXAMPLES OF ATROCITIES LIKE THIS
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN?
RUSSIA TARGETS PLACES WHERE
THERE ARE CIVILIANS.
NOT BY MISTAKE, IT SEEMS, BUT
KNOWINGLY, INTENTIONALLY.
>> WELL, FRED, IT SEEMS THAT IN
THEIR FRUSTRATION THAT THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO DELIVER
ANY BIG VICTORY IN TERMS OF A
TERRITORIAL AREA SEIZED IN
EASTERN UKRAINE TO VLADIMIR
PUTIN IN TIME FOR VICTORY DAY,
THEY SEEM TO BE DOUBLING DOWN ON
THIS PRACTICE THAT WE HAVE SEEN
FROM THE BEGINNING OF THIS
CONFLICT OF HITTING ANYWHERE
THAT MIGHT HURT THE UKRAINIANS
AND HOPEFULLY IN RUSSIA'S EYES,
MAKE THEM WITHDRAW.
HEEDLESS AND SOME UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS SAY INTENTIONALLY
HITTING CIVILIAN TARGETS.
NOW, THAT IS GOING TO BE A
DIFFICULT ONE TO PROVE.
IT'S GOING TO BE SOMETHING THAT
WE SEE PLAYING OUT YEARS FROM
NOW LIKELY IN WAR CRIMES TRIALS.
BUT IT IS DEVASTATING AND
PAINFUL TO WATCH.
AND IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
WHEN THE INTERNATIONAL RED CROSS
AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS ARE AB